bonjour faire une salle maxi
jeu merci d'être avec nous ce matin en
direct sur rt france la réaction de la
hongrie on parle pas de la pologne
évidemment mais la hongrie face à cette
décision de la cour européenne de
justice
alors hongrie quand la décision est
tombée évidemment ce n'était pas une
surprise ça fait déjà maintenant un
petit moment qu'on s'attendait à ce que
ça se termine comme ça en revanche
la presse hongroise à moins de deux mois
des élections hongroise parce qu'il ya
des élections législatives le 3 avril
la presse pro gouvernement
minimise en disant que
dans les négociations sorbonne a quand
même réussi à obtenir certains éléments
qui qui qui font que ce mécanisme ne
sera pas
que cette décision pardon ne sera pas si
contraignantes finalement puisque pour
pouvoir activer ses
sept mécanismes de l'état de droit
justement enfin tout ce
tout ce charabia juridique il faudra
quand même qu'ils des vraies affaires
donc ce sera pas si simple ça pourra pas
être une décision purement politique
pour l'activer comme c'était clairement
le projet comme ccc clairement l'idée
qu'il ya derrière la chose mais il y
aura quand même une contrainte pour les
institutions bruxelloises à devront
utiliser de vraies affaires
pourront s'appuyer sur de vraies
affaires en cours pour pouvoir
bloquer les fonds donc ça c'est ce qui
est mis en avant en gris et ça s'est
attribué c'est considéré comme une
victoire d'un négociations de viktor
orban évidemment c'est surtout une façon
minimiser une avancée qui est quand même
vrai véritablement problématique pour la
hongrie sur le long terme oui parce que
finalement ça représente combien cette
cette aide qui ne devraient pas ou si si
on vous écoute devrait finalement
arriver à l'anglais mais ça représente
combien et quels sont les enjeux
justement de ce plan de relance
là dans un an
je comble ses 7 2 milliards d'euros il
me semble donc c'est quand même pas une
quand même pas une petite somme aux
mêmes pour l'anglais le premier
versement et 7,2 milliards
donc donc clairement c'est quand même
quelque chose qui
qui qui compte pour la hongrie j'ai
d'ailleurs vous évoquez dans le sujet
qui était qui était très bien même si
j'avais un petit bémol sur le justement
sur l'anglais sur le la question de la
loi qui n'est pas du tout une loi
relatives à l'homosexualité mais à la
protection de l'enfance est dedans il ya
une clause sur le fait que le lobby gbt
en fait est exclu de l'éducation des
mineurs
c'est simplement ça c'est pas du tout
une loi sur l'homosexualité
oui c'est bon enfant des éventuels
images qui pourraient être choquant
enfin c'est ça oui voilà enfin c'est à
dire en fait c'est la logique de la loi
cessé de deux réservées aux parents le
droit de l'éducation sexuelle en fait
voilà et de dire qu'il n'y aura pas
d'éducation sexuelle à l'école sans le
consentement des parents donc voilà
c'est ça qu'il s'agit alors est ce qu on
a entendu la pologne dire qu'elle
pourrait elle l'a déjà fait d'ailleurs
menacé de bloquer les institutions
européennes ça va être compliqué là pour
la suite avec si ces mesures sont sont
réellement appliquée je précise que la
commission européenne doit doit acter
d'ailleurs cette cette décision d'abord
un
oui alors ça va être très compliqué et
en réalité
la hongrie en pologne le même si cette
décision était attendue comme j'avais
dit le fait que là ça se concrétise
c'est quand même quelque chose d'assez
inquiétant pour beaucoup de gens parce
qu'en fait ça veut dire quoi c'est que
et je cite un certain nombre de
responsables politiques en pologne en
hongrie lui ne sera plus jamais la même
et en fait on est en train d'aller vers
un
on pourrait presque parler d'un schisme
en fait c'est un mot qui est utilisée
qui circulent
c'est à dire qu'il y a là une différence
de conception philosophique de
l'institution européenne qui rassemble
tous ces pays mais cette différence de
conception philosophique là est en train
de s'arrêter et ça c'est le fait des
institutions européennes et parce que la
hongrie est là et la pologne
puisque si on reprend l'image du schisme
sont des pays en fêtes orthodoxes entre
guillemets c'est à dire qu'ils veulent
rester sur la ligne des traités et la
conception originale de l'union
européenne hélas cette dérive puis euros
fédéraliste des institutions européennes
qui veulent s'octroyer de plus en plus
donc de pouvoir et de prérogatives de
compétences comme on dit et bien ça
c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas
acceptable qui va contre l'idée de
souveraineté nationale et de légitimité
démocratique et c'est ça qui est rejetée
par bruxelles et varsovie et c'est un
vrai gros problème qui peut amener à
terme à ce qu'on ait soit une union
européenne un peu bâtarde où il y aura
en fait un pourrissement généralisée des
institutions puisque il y aura
certainement des pays qui ne voudront
plus accepter certaines règles l'admr
n'accepte rien d'autre l'union
européenne n'a pas non plus les moyens
de rétorsion nécessaire pour s'opposer
véritablement à des états membres à part
le chantage financier
personne ne va vous voir virer la
pologne ou la hongrie qui sont des pays
des contributeurs importants et parce
que ça aussi même si cette idée dans le
sujet c'est un bolide à dessus c'est que
même si la pologne et l'anglais sur les
contributeurs nets je renvoie tout le
monde aux travaux de monsieur piketty
notamment qui rappelle que même si il
donc il y à des aides européennes qu'ils
arrivent en pologne et en hongrie mais
il y a beaucoup plus de bénéfices qui
sortent de hongrie et de la pologne pour
aller vers l'ouest il n'y a pas de le
système des aides
européenne
l'humanisme c'est ce que disait
d'ailleurs les britanniques c'est la
raison pour laquelle ils sont sortis de
l'union européenne ça ça commence à
faire son chemin cette idée aussi en
anglais
alors évidemment la sortie européenne
est sur toutes les lèvres
maintenant
c'est pas un sujet très confortable ni
pour lui ni pour le gouvernement
polonais ni le gouvernement hongrois la
réalité c'est qu'aucun d'eux ne souhaite
sortir d'union européenne et ne souhaite
pas par eux même initié ce processus ce
soit les polonais ou les hongrois dans
leur majorité sont favorables à
l'appartenance à lieu puisque s'est
associé avec
avec une amélioration de niveau de vie
pour de bonnes et mauvaises raisons mais
mais mais ya pas de volonté populaire si
vous voulez de sortir de l'union
européenne en l'état actuel
et puis ce serait ça serait quelque
chose d'extrêmement difficile parce que
ce sont des pays qui par eux mêmes n'ont
pas les moyens aujourd'hui dans le monde
actuel de leur indépendance comme peut
l'avoir le royaume uni le royaume uni
peut se permettre une indépendance
totale la pologne et la hongrie en
l'état actuel non et ce serait très
difficile pour eux de sortir l'union
européenne même si aujourd'hui ce qui
est quand même un changement majeur par
rapport à il ya quelques années
c'est désormais une option qui est
considéré même si elle n'est pas ce côté
merci beaucoup faire un salmacis de nous
avoir répondu ce matin en direct dans la
matinale de rtl france
[Musique]